Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm so nervous.
There's a lot of new people.
Okay, so...
Hello, people on the official Bandai channel.
They're like, what the...
I'm trying not to swear.
I guess I'm on the official channel.
They're like, who the heck is this anime girl talking to me right now?
What the heck?
This says Dragon Ball Z 2023.
What is this?
That's not Dragon Ball.
I'm sorry.
I noticed the YouTube title was like, Dragon Ball Z Sparkling Zero 2023.
And I was like, wow!
They're in for some disappointment.
Hello, hello, hello.
There's gonna be a lot of new people here watching.
So, I'm nervous, guys.
I'm so nervous.
A lot of people are gonna...
So, anyway.
My name is Doki Bird.
I am an indie VTuber who primarily specializes in shooters, FPS, third-person, all that stuff.
I have high rankings.
I've been top 500 in Overwatch, Apex, and peak top 30 in Marvel Rivals.
Last season.
Or this season, actually.
Last season, I ended top 500 in Marvel Rivals.
So, I'm here to talk to you guys about Senuality and the Echo of Ada.
And it just launched recently.
Yeah, I know.
The Bandai chat is very confused.
I know.
It doesn't help that it says Dragon Ball Z.
They're like, this isn't Dragon Ball Z.
Anyway.
So, I'm here to celebrate and introduce to people the launch of Senuality Echo of Ada.
And for those completionists out there, I'm also giving away an exclusive code from watching the stream.
And I believe the code is limited time.
And it is for all platforms.
Also, I have a sound guy.
So, sound guy, please let me know if the volume is too loud.
Because I didn't keep any records from the previous sound balancing for this game.
So, if you use my code that I'll be showing on the stream, you will unlock a special t-shirt.
That's just me.
It has my face on it.
But it's also really good if you're a completionist.
Because you don't want to have this...
You don't want to be missing a shirt, you know, from your whole collection.
But for my fans out there, of course, they would really want this shirt.
Of course.
Because they're like, oh my gosh, a Dookie Boo shirt on an official Bandai game.
And all of that.
So, yes.
So, I'll be giving away a code for you guys.
So, you can claim it.
And unlock this special shirt that you can use in-game for your waifu.
I think the guys can wear it too.
But like, we all know it's for waifus.
By the way, I am hyped up and a lot of caffeine right now.
Because I had to wake up early.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I know this is not the sponsored part of this portion.
But like, I had to wake up early to go get my passport today.
So, I am hyped up and a lot of caffeine right now.
Because I was so tired lining up to get my passport today.
Because if I don't get it today, I have to wait Monday.
Because of bureaucracy and shit like that.
It really sucks.
I'm Canadian.
And we have to line- Okay, so like, when I got my passport, I had to like, line up.
I had to line up to go to the passport office.
And I had to line up to tell them I need my passport.
And then after I line up to tell them I need my pas- I need to renew my passport.
I had to line up to give them my application for my passport.
And then after that, it was like three hours of just lining up.
Lining up in three different lines.
And then I had to pick up my passport.
I had to line up to tell them what I have to do.
Why I'm here at the passport office.
And then after that, they made me line up to pick up my passport.
And you think it would be really fast because you're just picking up your passport.
But no!
They had to go through so many- Like, it was a long line.
It was- It was- It was- It was a long line.
And it was just- I thought it'd just be like, here you go.
Like, here's your- the receipt.
And they just give you the passport.
But then they'd be like- I don't know what they're checking.
I don't know what they're checking.
There's so many.
There's so many paperwork.
I'm sorry.
That's a little off topic.
For those who are new here and were like, I thought you were gonna show us sinuality.
I'm sorry.
I just got a little distracted there.
I usually do, like, life updates.
And I know this is a sponsored stream by me.
That's why I'm on Bandai right now.
That's why I'm on the official channels.
By the way, I'm not employed by Bandai.
I am a sponsored streamer.
That they have sponsored me to come here to talk to you guys about sinuality.
But this is basically, like, a snippet of my streams and stuff like that.
So please, if you're curious, check me out on Doki Bird.
I'm actually streaming on YouTube right now on my own channel.
But I'm doing a multi-stream right now.
This is my very first time doing a multi-stream.
I was very scared.
Because I've never done a multi-stream.
And then I also have to record this stream.
So that it puts on a loop on the Steam.
It's gonna be on looped.
The stream is gonna be looped on Steam as well.
When you are on sinuality.
And then I'm multi-streaming on both the Bandai official channel.
And also the Bandai official Twitch.
So I was like, is my PC gonna die?
I was Googling it.
And they were like...
It was like, you gotta have the bandwidth.
And like the internet.
And like the PC to handle all of this.
And then I looked at the instructions.
And I was like...
I was like, oh man.
My PC is either gonna god damn explode.
Or everything will be okay.
I could have tested it on like other channels.
But I was like, the fun part is to do it live.
I could have tested this out earlier.
I didn't realize.
I forgot about the recording part too.
I was just like, oh man.
I forgot I have to record.
I live for the rush.
Especially when I get paid for it.
I live for the potential for it messing up.
But anyway.
So I was just like, okay.
Clearly, you know, I was like multi-streaming on YouTube and Twitch.
And my own YouTube channel.
It can't be that bad.
But then I forgot about the recording part.
So then I was like, oh that could be a little risky.
That's a little bit too much.
So, if I suddenly disappear.
I hope I'm okay.
I hope I'm okay if I disappear.
Anyway, guys.
Alright, so.
Like I said.
I am ready to check out Senuality.
Well, to be fair, we checked it.
This is going to be our third time checking out Senuality.
But it's the official launch.
So more Dragoons, more fans.
You guys can go into my lobbies.
And then I'm going to steal your goddamn legs.
But the best part is that this time.
You can wear my t-shirt while I steal your legs.
So for those who don't know.
Senuality Echo of Ada is an extraction shooter.
So if you die, you lose everything.
Because I'm going to kill you.
Sorry.
In-game.
In Senuality.
Because if you die, most likely by me.
I'm going to steal your legs.
And then you lose everything.
And your waifu too.
Apparently I can kidnap your wives too.
So like, we've done it before.
Multiple times.
And I'm looking forward to that.
So don't go in thinking you're not going to lose everything.
Because you will.
And it's going to be to me.
Anyway.
To my sound guy.
Yes, I can see your messages.
I can see mostly on my own channel messages.
So like just put it on my channel.
There's a lot of chat messages going around.
But like, I cannot.
Oh my gosh.
I already am multi-streaming.
There's too many chat things everywhere.
So like, at best, comment.
My mods, please comment on my YouTube channel.
So I know what's going on.
If you don't, I will freak out.
Alright.
So yes, let me know about the sound later on.
If everything is okay.
Anyway guys, let's actually get into it.
This is actually my third time checking out Senuality.
We've checked it.
We're going to create our waifu for the third time.
I don't remember what she looked like anymore.
It's been a while.
Oh, I forgot to do the options.
God damn it.
Okay.
I forgot the options part.
I'm trying my best guys.
Alright.
So...
For those...
Basically, it's like...
Mecha waifu's extraction shooter.
So if you know like, games...
Like...
Tarkov...
It's like...
That, but like mechas.
And with hotter waifus and that stuff.
So like, it's actually an improvement if you think about it.
Alright.
Not...
Doki.
How would they know?
If I name...
How is no one ever still not Doki?
I don't understand.
It's like the best name...
Out there.
Okay.
This is the third time I watched this intro.
But to be honest, I already...
I feel like...
Um...
I feel like I need to rewatch this again.
How would they know?
I'm totally ready.
You can tell I'm really hyped up and caffeine right now.
Not okay.
Alright, brought up overall sound, guys.
Oh my god, that's so crazy.
Oh my god,
so very cool.
For reasons unknown to this day, the great city of Amasia collapsed.
Humanity returned to the surface, but faced constant energy shortages.
As if that were not enough of a challenge, Enders, an unknown lifeform, appeared, further threatening humanity.
Oh my god.
The evil Y-Hot.
That's us.
That's gonna be us, basically.
We're the Drifters.
I'll bring up a little bit more.
Okay.
Can't wait to mine.
So... that's their hot android waifus.
Or husbandos, but like...
We checked the rank- the last time...
The last time we played this game, we checked the top 500 rankings for this game.
And there was only one player that had a guy as their companion.
The solo chat amongst the waifus.
That's where we're proud of.
Then we can be evil too and kill other Drifters.
For money.
And to kidnap other Drifters waifus.
Which is like- I mean like...
Being a good guy is so goddamn boring.
Like,
why become friends when we can just kill each other in game?
It makes life more exciting, you know?
Tokino!
Thank you for watching.
The final section of the selection exam will now begin.
We wish you the best of luck.
Please proceed to your mark in the little coffin.
Alright, so we are basically dropped into- the tutorial is really fast.
Like, I've done this tutorial like three times already.
This is gonna be my third time doing this tutorial.
Spoken like a true League- So this is our temporary waifu.
I like how this is my third time, but I still forget how- I still forget the instructions.
Alright, we gotta look at the display.
Clear, clear.
It always surprises me every time.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I forgot.
I need to...
Motion blur off.
Guys, I can't fix the gra- I keep forgetting to fix the graphics settings, guys.
Sorry.
The graphics for this game is so- I might be lagging a little bit.
I'm sorry.
Just...
Give me a sec.
We gotta finish the tutorial.
And then I- My waifu is way too HD right now.
So I need to finish the tutorial.
And then everything will be okay.
I can't- I can't adjust anything yet until I- Until I finish the tutorial.
So like- My waifu is just too pretty.
Too beautiful.
So that's why I look like this right now.
So she can look like that.
Don't worry.
I can do this really fast though.
Alright.
I'm gonna touch grass for the first time.
I'm sorry.
I gotta make sure you look a little uglier, waifu.
So I can- I can actually move.
I look like this.
So she can move like that.
But- But- Guys, the sacrifices I make for her.
I- She's not even my- My permanent waifu.
I do it for her.
She's not even my permanent waifu.
She's so little.
She's like my- My teacher.
I do it for her.
AO search.
What was it again?
Uh, C.
Okay, AO searches.
C.
Okay, it was time to get the crystals.
Oh my god.
But at least it's so- At least it's beautiful.
Let's run over the dog.
The things I do for her.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta speedrun this.
I'm sorry.
I know you guys are like, Yoki, please read the- Guys, we gotta- We have to speedrun this so I can fix my graphics.
I can at least move at 30 frames.
Like, that's the goal.
Alright, and then basically- Excavate real fast.
Alright, let's pick this up.
Guys, guys, please.
We're almost there.
Like, we have like, three more- Two more sections of this tutorial.
Guys, we're almost there.
I always forget.
I always forget how- How many polygons my wife has.
Like, every time.
You'd think I would learn after the first- First time playing.
But I keep forgetting.
I'll be like, alright, let's just go in.
But then I forget- I forgot that my wife has so many polygons.
That like- Like, I have to look like this for a bit until I get to the settings.
I never learn.
I just never learn.
But I learned how to multi-stream.
Oh no, by the way, water hurts me.
For those who are new here and forgot about that.
Or like, being like, who the hell is this anime girl?
Water hurts me, just like real life.
I'm already having to touch grass and now I have to deal with water.
It's like basically acid rain.
Oh, the sound, guys.
Does the sound better now?
Water's my mortal enemy.
Yeah, the wicked witch of the west.
Because it forces me to- Okay, guys.
I actually shower, guys.
But as a gamer, I am obligated to make a- Gamers don't shower joke, but I do shower.
I legitimately- I shower today, guys.
I am not a fake gamer.
Just because you shower, that's- Oh, who cares about the rain?
Just, you know, I don't even care.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I am getting damaged by rain.
Can you not talk faster?
Okay.
Okay, so I remember I can do the multi-skill.
So each wife has like its own unique skill.
That like is basically for a specific playstyle.
So this wife basically- This wife's playstyle is a PvE playstyle.
Okay, and then I have to open the door.
How do I send it?
Okay, here we go.
Yay, the rain stopped!
Yippee!
So you guys got my mandatory shower.
With acid rain.
And then I just started blasting- Oh shit.
There's no fall damage, so you're fine.
Alright, and then we head home.
Don't make it weird.
Alright, heading home now.
Alright, so once your durability reaches zero, your unit will be destroyed and you'll lose both your- Oh, like I said, this is an extraction shooter.
So if you die, you lose everything unless you get insurance.
But I ain't no coward and I don't get insurance.
It's like when you- Oh yeah, she's- I'm on the- Doki, you're on the official Bandai channel.
You can't say really messed up stuff right now because you might not be able to get away with it.
I was gonna say, why get insurance?
It's better to get insurance, guys.
Especially if you live in places where, you know, hospital bills are very expensive.
Insurance is really good.
Anyway, so there are- Alright guys, now that I'm not lagging anymore.
Make sure you put your insurance on your waifus too.
So, there's like four different templates you can choose.
Nobody picks him.
I wonder why.
I'm sorry, Beta.
Also, they're apparently called Betas and the women are Alphas.
So like, you can sort of tell why no one wants to pick the Beta.
We're not picking the Beta male!
You guys are a very vocal minority.
I swear, last time I gave you guys a chance to vote for it.
And I saw a lot of Beta people asking for the Beta male character.
But then, when I put up the poll, the Alpha woman won.
Like, you guys are like so vocal, but yet there's like ten of you.
I won't be surprised if you made like twenty counts each to make yourself look like you're the majority.
Like, re-roll.
Come on, let us re-roll.
Alright, I swear, if I made the poll and gave you guys a minute to choose the character, the Alpha woman will still win.
The lurker majority will still outpace you.
Alright, alright, let's see.
Beta male, Alpha woman.
Who should my wife, my android waifu husbando be?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I'll give you guys... For those who want to know, where are we voting?
Where are we voting?
It is usually... This is our default.
IBAlpha09 is our default.
Then a lot of...
The vocal... Oh, look at that!
The Alpha woman won with a 69% majority.
Look at that!
For those who are wondering, where are we voting?
We're voting on my main channel on YouTube at Toki Bird.
But wow!
What a surprise!
Oh wow!
It even went up a percentage!
It went up!
Cowards!
Oh my god, it keeps going up!
I literally... And then if I scroll up and look at my chat, I see so many people that were like, Come on, let us try!
Reroll, coward!
Make the pull!
Pick him, you coward!
Rigged!
Pull again!
I have not seen... I've only seen one person in the sea of beta male be waifu, of course.
So I was like, if we scream loud enough, we can win!
No!
Double or... nothing!
Jdu, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Guys messed up.
Beta male would be funnier because it's what streamers don't want.
Thank you for the super chat, Jdu!
Thank you, thank you!
Weak chat goes for not voting for beta male.
Mike, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wow, look at that!
The alpha woman has won for the third time!
The silent... look at that!
The silent majority has won yet again!
Remember the vote!
Alright.
Okay, so we wanna be... we wanna be...
God, I love women.
We wanna have...
Which one was the one that specializes on specifically PvP?
Because I'm here to beat up other players.
That's right, I'm coming for you.
Alright, a system specializing in anti-cradle combat.
I think it was this, right?
Okay, anti-cradle.
Displays cradle's health, features a magic skill that restrains any...
Oh, it's this one, yeah.
So anti-cradle is basically...
Also, like, who wants to be a weatherman?
Okay, so there's one other skill that's called weathergazer.
And all you do is just tell the weather.
I'm sorry, but that is such a useless waifu skill.
You're literally like a news reporter.
I've killed many weathergazer because I know they don't know what to do.
So...
So if you are a weatherman or a reporter, I will hunt you down.
Because I know you have nothing.
I ended the weatherman.
Alright, so there's cradle support.
This one is mostly like, it heals you more.
And this one is like for PvE, anti-enders.
This one is PvP, and then defensive, I believe, is just...
I just focus on defensive in general.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's...
I wanted to make myself, right?
I don't remember how I made myself last time.
Oh yeah, it was this.
It was retro doki.
They don't have classic doki.
They don't have, like, current doki.
So, like, let's make retro doki.
Oh, but then... No, wait, I can be dead mom doki.
Oh my god, I should be dead mom doki.
Okay.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna make...
I'm gonna make dead mom doki.
Alright, let's see.
Honestly, everything else is perfect at that point.
I just really needed the different hair.
Alright, and then...
Let's see.
Yeah, very accurate.
There you go.
Just a little...
Just very, very accurate.
Oh yeah, the eye color.
I almost forgot my eyes.
Eye color.
I need to look at my own eyes.
Because sometimes I don't pay attention to what my eyes are.
Eye color.
There you go.
This is me in the future.
Because I'll be... Oh, I'm sorry.
End game.
Okay, alright.
I think everything is...
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
Complete.
Yes.
Real...
Doki.
Alright.
Request accepted.
By the way, I'm sponsored by Bandai.
This is gonna be looped on the Steam page.
If you see this on Steam...
That means the stream got approved.
Oh yeah, my own house again.
We're counting on you to mine precious AO crystals.
Hey, nice.
Can't wait for my...
Waifu to not actually clean my base...
For the third time.
This is my welcome to my gamer crib.
There are a lot of jokes I really wanna make.
But then I have to remember I am on the official channel.
The things that are getting through...
It's been rough.
Yes, I live like this.
I'm a gamer.
You think gamers with millions...
I don't have millions of dollars, by the way.
Guys, I don't have millions of dollars.
But you guys all know...
Gamers with millions of dollars...
Also still live like this.
All we need is...
Legitimately, all we need...
Is a PC...
And a fridge to put all our...
All our ready-made...
Actually, who am I lying?
A lot of gamers just Uber Eats.
What are you doing?
Okay, she's just...
She's just cleaning, as always.
Oh, I have school uniforms?
Oh my god!
Alright, guys!
I think...
Wait, I can get a new waifu already?
Let's alter the existing...
Okay.
Okay, so...
Now, it's time...
To...
Okay, I hope I'm doing this correctly.
Okay, before we do that...
Let me fix my graphics settings real fast.
Let me...
Okay, low...
2x...
I'm sorry, waifu.
But like...
I love how you look...
But like, I'm struggling right now.
I'm struggling at the moment.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, so...
Let me get the code out.
So, like I said...
There is an exclusive...
Doki Bird t-shirt...
That you can claim...
In-game, right now!
Let me grab the code real quick for all of you guys.
And I'm gonna pin it...
I'm gonna pin it on the channel...
On the...
In the YouTube chat, and I'll put it on the screen too.
For those who are on the other channels.
I think I believe...
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know if there's mods that can like...
Put the code on the other channels.
I'm multi-streaming right now.
But let me grab the code real quick.
And then I'll show you how to do it.
So, basically all you have to do...
Is you go to...
Options.
You have to be in the base first.
You gotta be in base.
I found out that you can't do it...
When you boot up the game for the first time.
So you go to other.
And then you enter...
Serial code entry, right here.
And then, I just...
Okay, let me see if I copied and pasted the right thing.
It'd be so weird if I had like something else that I copied and pasted.
And then, this is literally the code.
You click confirm.
And then, Doki Bird...
Okay, wait.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I just realized I have...
Sorry.
I covered it.
Look at that.
Doki Bird t-shirt and a Bandai game.
That's me.
You guys wanna know who Doki Bird is?
Alright.
Anyway, so like I said.
You go to other, serial code entry.
You click here.
You just copy and paste and then confirm.
That's basically it.
It's so easy.
Also, do not enter the incorrect code 10 times.
Or you'll get an error.
You can claim this on any platform.
You buy...
You buy Senuality Echo Veda.
So you buy it on Playstation.
You buy it on the PC.
It can be on any platform.
Let me pin it real...
See, I'm not scamming you guys.
Hahaha.
Go to claim Doki Bird t-shirt.
Alright.
Let me pin this real quick now.
Uh...
And then let me put it on...
Alright.
There you go.
Code for shirt.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's a little too big.
Here you guys go.
For those who are...
On the other platform.
Yes, it is time limited.
I don't know when it ends.
So like, that's a surprise.
I'm asking right now.
When does the code end?
That's the best part.
It's a surprise.
You don't know when it's gonna end.
That's a very good question.
Let me ask real quick to the...
To the Bandai staff.
It means that like...
You will have the shirt forever.
But...
Claiming it is time limited.
So the shirt is gonna be in your account forever.
It's just that...
I don't remember when it ends.
When it comes to like claiming the code.
So like...
That's the issue right now.
Other than that...
Wow!
I'm officially in the game, everybody.
Technically.
Alright, let's see if there's anything else I can do to fix this up.
Alright, so...
Now, you can see...
We can give my waifu...
Some shirts.
So, where's my shirt?
Oh my god, that's so cute though.
Okay, I believe...
I think the code is so ugly.
Oh my god, wait, that's so cute.
Wait, oh my god, wait, that's so cute.
Okay, no, you gotta...
You're sponsored, you gotta put your...
You gotta put your shirt.
Where's my shirt?
Wait, where is my shirt?
Give me a sec, I need to find my shirt real quick, guys.
Okay, tops...
Eyeglasses, hat...
Wait, I get to have tails?
Wait, I get to have a tail?
Oh my god, wait, that's so cute.
Wait, guys, I'm sorry.
I should... I need to put on my own clothes.
Wait, where's my shirt though?
Wait, oh, drifter pass.
Oh, there's a battle pass?
Wait.
Once you reach the highest, you'll be granted an EX rank.
When you gain EXP, whenever you gain a certain amount...
You can receive EXP rank rewards.
Okay.
Wait, what does the...
Oh, you can like, claim like...
Cuter wives.
That would never replace me.
That would never replace my OG waifu.
She's here forever.
Wait, did I not fully claim it?
Oh my gosh, guys, I'm a professional.
Okay, let me try this again.
No, I did!
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, I have to go to the top, sorry.
Afterwards, you go... Guys, I'm a professional.
But after you claim the code, and you're like...
Where's the code?
Yeah, return back to the title screen.
I knew that.
I...
Guys...
I knew that, guys.
Of course I do.
It's a sponsored stream.
I'm so prepared.
It was funny...
The staff before I started the stream...
Was like...
Oh yeah, remember...
Remember to claim it.
Go back to the start to claim it.
Oh my god, there it is!
I was like, I got you.
Alright, so there it is!
There's my shirt!
Oh my god, there it...
Okay, I need to...
Alright, I just want to make sure she has...
No pants here.
Actually, I don't know.
Okay, the white shoes is pretty cute.
Oh, the yellow shoes matches, I feel like.
And then... Wait, do I have glasses?
Oh my god, I can just be blind.
I'm sorry.
If you see the hair, it's like this right now.
The hair looks a lot better.
It's just that like...
Me and my wife have to make sacrifices for each other.
Okay, like...
I'm sorry.
I'm streaming right now.
So like, I'm sorry that you have to look like this for a little bit.
Just for a little bit.
Okay, and then...
No, actually...
Yeah, this is perfect.
Oh, okay.
Let's see.
No, I think this is perfect.
The IV extra bodice suit looks so nice on her.
But yes, there's my t-shirt.
Okay, just for the sake of the fact that like...
You know, I gotta make sure it looks really nice.
Give me a sec.
I realize like...
It should be better if I actually...
Alright, just for everybody to look at how beautiful my wife is.
Let me put it on high real quick.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Look at her.
She's beautiful.
There we go.
And that's how you claim my shirt.
Right here.
That's how you claim it.
Let me just...
Now I need to put her at like 10 polygons.
Let me put her back at 10 polygons real quick.
Alright, anyway.
So yeah, that's my beautiful wife.
With my beautiful shirt.
Buy my merch.
I don't have this as merch, but buy my other merch.
Oh, and also I can make her do settings too.
Alright, so okay.
So like, this is my favorite part.
About...
This is my favorite part.
The stuff you can do.
In Extraction Shooter.
It's the fact that like...
You can emote to other actual players.
And...
The thing is...
Other players in this game...
Try to be friendly.
And then...
You can try to be friendly too.
But like...
It doesn't mean you're genuine.
like, when...
HAHAHAHAHA!
It doesn't mean...
You have to mean it.
haha
And that's the best part.
So here are the request that you have to do.
These are like mini missions when you start out.
So the whole thing is...
You have to upgrade your base and like...
Make it a better and better base and get more resources to improve your base and everything.
So I said...
This is where you basically get your like missions and stuff So basically I have to bring back some AO crystals and then this is like the top 500 the ranking so you can tell a lot about the people by like how Hot, okay.
Sorry, not hot.
You can tell a lot about the people in this game by what they're what they're Waifus look like so you can tell exactly like, you know They're in their soul by
How they make their Android waifu So this guy went default this guy doesn't care this guy actually is there to just play the game Nora Everyone else is like customizing their Android but like Nora over here is actually just here to game He just went default and was like it's perfect That's a gamer right there Look at that.
Now, let's see when we hit like...
Now, this is where we realized that like...
No one had no... Okay.
We already are at like 54, but we have yet to see a husbando.
That's all I'm gonna say.
We have yet to see a beta male and we are at 58 right now.
And at that point, that's when I knew that the beta male...
The beta male lovers are a very vocal minority.
Not the beta male.
I'm sure there's... I don't know.
We are at 65 right now.
He's out for blood.
Apparently, the last time we found... Okay.
The one... The one time we found like a beta male enjoyer is like within the um...
It's within the bounty hunter category.
So like... I believe it's this one, right?
Is it this one?
Loser boy?
Oh, yeah.
This is like... This is basically the people who are here to kill.
So like...
Um, all these people are evil... are evil people.
So...
These are the murderers in this world.
I like how there's some guy Harmo at Twitch.
So these are the murderers.
Uh, but like I said...
I have yet to see a beta male.
Oh, there it is!
Number seven!
All right.
I like how his name is Jarvis.
He named him Jarvis!
He named as a beta male Jarvis!
Of course, of course he did.
Jarvis clipped that.
Jarvis was this anime girl in my... in my anime game.
All right, that was our... the only time we saw a beta male.
Oh, yeah, I forgot to do the audio 65... the 65 sound effects.
All right.
Thank you, Yoshio.
I really appreciate the educational video.
I love these animations.
I think these animations are really cute.
It reminds me of like...
Uh, I don't know.
It's just really cute in general.
Nice stroll on the surface.
Take note of where materials can be found.
And keep your eyes out for the ever-important A.O.
crystals.
Collect those A.O.
crystals because you can exchange them for cash.
I love the little mech legs.
Me too.
That's why it inspires me to...
To just be like just there to steal the legs.
That's literally my inspiration right now.
All right, anyway, so...
Thank you, wife, for washing my dishes.
Um, let me increase the sound effects volume.
Real quick and then that should be good.
And then, uh...
Swordy prep.
So this is where you prep for your mission.
If you're lazy like me...
Guess you automate it.
Because I don't want to bring... Oh, I could bring in my own legs, but I feel like I said so much shit.
I feel like somebody's gonna try and rob, you know...
Okay, I'll get... I can get insurance.
I believe.
Okay.
All right, I believe.
Okay, I'll just bring in... I'll just bring in...
I'll just bring in DLC legs.
I feel like I'm gonna get robbed, but like I believe.
Okay, so you can lose items.
But if you don't want to lose items, obviously you can insurance them.
So like right now, I'm...
I need... Okay, how much money do I have?
Okay.
Apparently, I'm broke.
So this is a little awkward.
So I'm risking it all right now.
Um, I'm...
I'm risking it all right now, hoping that I won't get robbed.
I like how someone's like, you don't need insurance, you live in Canada.
All right, let's hope that I get to keep my DLC legs.
Get her, she has the DLC!
That's right, you can't get me if I'm faster though.
All right.
So...
Like I said, this is an extraction shooter.
So it's all about trying to get loot and...
And kill the other players and everything.
Um...
No, I'm pretty sure I have heals, right?
Did I pack heals?
No, I'm pretty sure I did.
There's no way I didn't.
There's no way.
There's no way I forgot one of the most important things.
Heals and ammo.
I pressed automated replacements.
There's no way I didn't get ammo.
I pressed M.
There's no way.
I didn't get any ammo.
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, what happened to my inventory?
Okay, let's head home.
We're gonna head home straight away.
We're heading home.
I'm gonna head home.
This is very dangerous.
I'm a little scared.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right, I'm gonna try and head home.
Really?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
All right, don't worry.
We're gonna... our main mission is to survive right now.
There's no...
Our main mission right now is to survive.
There's no way.
Oh no.
They don't know who I am.
Okay.
All right, guys.
This is looking a little rough right now.
I don't remember if... there is fall damage, by the way.
Guys, guys, there is...
From what I remember, there is absolutely is fall damage.
Okay, I don't hear anybody.
We're very safe.
Okay.
We gotta be careful.
We have zero bullets.
Oh no.
I'm gonna jump.
Okay.
Okay, it's okay.
Everything is fine.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Okay, that's okay.
They don't know I'm here.
All right, that's... that's the... that's how to get out of here.
All right.
That's a gazing.
They fire long-range attacks from above.
Watch for signs of incoming attacks.
That's the... okay.
It's fine.
The mission right now is to survive because I forgot to bring bullets.
I forgot to bring any bullets.
It's okay.
We should be fine.
I hear zero gunshots around me.
We should be okay.
There are zero gunshots around me.
We'll just ride around.
We'll just...
All right.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
All right.
Oh no.
No.
No, there's an engine near me.
Oh no, there's an engine near me.
Please.
There's an engine near me.
Oh my god.
Please.
I don't want people to find me.
I don't have... you can't... you can't... you can't kill me.
I have nothing.
Oh, it's okay.
We're surviving.
We're... we have zero bullets.
We have zero ammo.
I... I forgot to bring it.
The one thing I forgot.
Oh my god.
We're okay.
All right.
So like, please disregard this first mission.
I forgot to bring the most important thing in this game.
I forgot which is ammo.
I...
I forgot... oh, there's gunfire near me.
Oh my god.
There's gunfire near me.
Oh no, they don't know.
Okay, we're safe.
All right.
Nice mission success, guys.
We did it.
Look at that, guys.
And that's how you do a mission, everybody.
That's... we might not have accomplished much, but I survived and I still have my legs.
All right, so every map... game you get to see like...
Like, you know, what happened basically in the background.
So like, there's nobody around me.
Thank god at that point.
I don't think they're...
Successfully... no, no, no.
Not a coward.
I had zero ammo.
I was basically unarmed.
You don't shoot an unarmed man.
Is there like actual people next to me?
I can't tell.
Did anyone else realize where I am?
Okay, I think we can fast forward.
I'm actually curious.
Did anyone actually know where I am?
Oh, no.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
Never punished.
There was nobody near me.
There's no... I would never.
I would never shoot an unarmed mech, guys.
I would never do such a thing.
I got materials too.
I didn't complete my mission.
Wait, no, I did.
I got a daily.
Okay.
Okay, now...
Okay, let me teach you how to actually play this.
Look, I was trying to show you guys how to not play this game.
So, like, the basic first rookie mistake playing a Sinuality Echo of Ada is, you know, you forget to...
See?
My wife thought I did amazing.
She thought I did amazing.
So I was just teaching you guys how to not play the game.
And now I'm gonna teach you guys how to actually play Sinuality to make this game so much easier for all of you.
To make some critical repairs.
So, yeah, I live like this basically and she doesn't like that I live like this.
So because I had... you just press this and then now you have everything.
I have no idea how I forgot how this could have happened.
But now I... okay, I should bring more than... more than the one.
I don't know why it gave me one.
All right, so...
Now I have my repair kit and I'm ready for real this time.
Can I... okay, I still don't have enough money to...
To do insurance, but that's okay.
I have ammo now, so I'm not scared.
I am not scared this time because I have...
I have ammo, so I'm not afraid.
I don't need insurance.
I have DLC legs.
Currently no deaths.
All right, now let me show you how to actually play this game.
I know that shirt is so cute.
It's actually really cute.
It's cute because it's me.
All right.
Okay, now...
Now that there's nice weather.
Okay, where's the closest?
Oh my god.
It's like on the other side.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
So it's on the other side, so let me just...
We need to get crystals, so I believe I have to...
Where is it?
Wait, what?
Where is the AO crystals?
Oh, oh it's right here.
It's next to me.
All right, time to farm.
Time to farm.
It would be a shame if something happens to the person that tries to kill me.
Okay, I feel like I can find a lot of crystals just by heading there though.
I feel like...
There's no way like I...
I feel like I'm gonna bump into like so many other... so many crystals.
So I don't have to like actively look for them.
I keep trying to use my emotes.
All right.
Hello, anybody here?
Any friendly mechs like me?
Who is also incredibly friendly?
Anybody here?
Oh, I forgot to get my shotgun!
Okay, the shotgun is so much better.
I forgot to equip the shotgun.
I think the shotgun has to be the best weapon in this game.
Oh shit, not the... no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, let me get rid of him.
I don't- I don't like this.
Okay, let's get rid of these guys.
Why are you still here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh god, okay.
How is he so strong?
Perform repairs in a safe area.
Oh, no.
I cannot lose my DLC legs on this!
Okay, I didn't realize how strong they are.
I didn't realize how strong they are.
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
Are they still chasing me?
In a safe area.
Oh my god.
How do I repair?
I don't remember how to repair.
Oh, I'm freaking out.
Oh, it's H.
It's H.
Durability has been reduced.
You should conduct repairs now.
I'm still okay.
I'm- I'm so healthy.
I'm so healthy.
It's all right.
I'm not freaking out.
I'm not- guys, guys.
I'm not freaking out, guys.
I'm not.
Durability is partially back on the map.
I need to protect the leg.
Guys, I didn't realize they're that strong.
It's been so long!
It's been so long since I tried to kill a regular freak.
Okay.
Nah, guys.
I'm not- I- I was panicking, okay?
I was just panicking.
Um, I swear to god, it was a lot better before.
Oh my god.
Now, it's raining?
What is this?
Oh, no.
Where's the goddamn cover?
I'm trying to find a shelter.
It's all right.
A little rain doesn't hurt.
I'm on a terrible- are you serious?
Are you serious?
Oh my god, why are they so strong?
I'm just a baby!
I don't understand.
Why are they so strong?
I'm feeling just a child!
All right, everything is fine.
Okay, let's just...
Let's just get to cover.
Wait, is this- did it stop raining?
Okay, it stopped raining.
All right.
See?
Oh, it did not stop raining.
Is this covering me?
Oh my god.
Does this cover me?
Okay, there we go.
I'm safe now.
So, I gotta wait here because outside is scary.
They know my sins.
When did these guys get so strong?
I- they used to die so fast and now they take up like 80% of my health.
Who gave these monsters like performance enhancing...
pills?
Oh no, does he know I'm here?
Does he know I'm here?
He doesn't know I'm here.
He's just chilling.
The rain empowers me.
I'm so happy right now.
All right, nice.
Okay, wait.
Is this next to me?
Okay, I'm gonna go to this area.
I haven't found like a single...
Wait, it rained again?
Oh my god, what is wrong?
What did global warming do?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh no.
But showering too much is actually really bad for you.
Okay, so we have an escape route here.
But like I don't see anybody around me.
Where are the people?
If only, if only Doki could predict the weather.
We don't need to be we- being a weatherman.
Being a weatherman is a goddamn scam.
I'm trying to see if I could find- there has to be somebody that's also wants to escape, right?
Are there any friends?
Any friends here?
Come on, anybody wanna become friends with me?
Come on.
Look at this like...
Entrance way right here.
It's looking at so inviting and everything.
Does anyone want to be my friend?
There has to be somebody here.
Do not trust her.
What do you mean?
I'm such a kind robot, kind mech here to help out all the other mechs.
Come on, anybody wanna become a friend?
What is that?
Hello?
Anybody here?
Kind, what for- I- you don't know that.
You don't know if I'm anti-creative.
Sorry, that's my friendship thing.
It's for friendship only.
See?
Slowly go down with friendship.
Where are the friends?
Also, I need to buy- I need more health.
I accidentally- I actually messed up.
Go back.
I need to go back.
My friendship circle, exactly.
It's my friendship circle.
I actually messed up with the- with the mobs.
Assault.
All right, anyway, mission number two is another example of how not to play this game.
Look, I- I purposely let the mobs hit me to show you guys just how strong the mobs are if you don't pay attention.
And how you have to grab shotgun instead of the other guns because shotgun is like so much better than the other regular guns until you get better- until you get better equipment, obviously.
There has to be friends somewhere.
Is it because I just started that they put me in the baby lobby?
No way.
Where- where's everybody?
Is it just because I'm in- oh my god.
Are all of you guys like professionals now?
I haven't seen anybody around me yet.
There's no one here.
All right, end search replay.
Probably I'm in the baby lobby because of the stuff I've been doing.
They're like this- This person is not doing- this person forgot to bring ammo.
We gotta put him in the baby lo- Oh my god.
We gotta put her in the baby lobby until she knows how to bring ammo.
You know like the bottom 500.
They're like, all right, we gotta make sure she doesn't get like- She doesn't get killed by 20 people.
She doesn't get killed by 20 people.
See, see, this is where I'm showing skill-based matchmaking actually works, guys.
I didn't bring ammo and then the game was like, oh no.
They're like, oh no, she's one of those players.
I'm crazy.
The moment I get out of the kiddie pool, I'll show you how a real gamer works.
Oh shit, nice.
I got- I got gloves.
All right, nice.
I got new requests.
What's my new request?
All right, the next mission is where my training wheel gets out- goes out.
Obviously, the more missions you complete, the better rewards you get.
This is the run.
This is the run!
This will be the run where we meet somebody.
I'll get out of the kiddie pool today.
This is where I get out of the kiddie pool.
Yay!
Helping- see guys?
Helping others helps you.
See?
I love helping people.
Real.
All right.
Uh, so I can- do I have enough money?
If you're gonna play a garage, try repairing.
Okay, this is where I have to- oh, I don't.
I need more metal scraps.
So I need to like, find more resources so I can upgrade my gaming pad.
Yes, guys.
Doesn't anyone want to be my friend?
All right, so I need more- I need more repair kits because I'm running out of that.
Which one- is this a shotgun?
Okay, I'm gonna grab the shotgun.
I'm gonna throw away the shotgun.
Uh, we need shotgun because shotgun is the strongest gun in this- in this game.
Uh, cable equipping both live and energy ammo.
Uh, allows a long and high movement to reinforce improved damage reduction.
Wait, it has damage reduction.
Wait.
Wait, that's good.
All right, that's right.
Now I have- okay.
No, no, no.
I should have- No, I should have the bad head so people will think I'm a baby.
So they'll treat me nicer because I'm a ba- They'll treat me nicer because I'm a baby.
So they'll be like, oh, oh man, obviously she doesn't know what she's doing.
No, they don't look at- they- gamers don't look down.
So they don't want to look at my legs.
They won't look at my legs.
It's gonna be a- We're gonna be- we're gonna- they'll think I'm a baby and then I'll give them like a false sense of security.
And because I give them a false sense of security, um, they'll think that like, um, they'll think that, you know, um, I'm no threat.
I'm not a threat to them.
Okay, let's get rid of this.
I have the heavy energy ammo.
All right, they won't think I'm a threat.
Gamers don't look up and down.
Gamers just look in the center.
Okay.
That's me!
Yeah, I got the correct ammo.
What?
Really?
Don't listen to him.
Turn your- make sure to always turn your backs, especially towards baby drifters.
Don't- he doesn't know what he's talking about.
Don't listen to him.
He's not even- he's not even hot.
Are you really gonna listen to somebody that's not even hot?
Hahaha
Yeah, he doesn't know what he's doing.
He doesn't even have actual legs.
Come on, guys.
Where's his legs?
All right, this is where- this is where I get out of the kiddie pool.
This is it.
I'm ready.
I'm out of the kiddie pool now.
Okay, there has to be someone over here.
I'm literally gonna go across the- What's my current objective?
All right, hello, is there anybody here?
Look, I'm holding a really bad gu- There's a faint sound.
Wait, wait, there's people.
Wait, there's people.
Wait.
There's people.
Wait, you see that?
You see that?
That's a person.
Hello.
Hello, I am so friendly.
Hello, I just got here.
And I'm here to make friends.
Hello.
Where did he go?
He was like right here.
Wait, where did he go?
No, those are- There's like regular PvE people.
Wait, where's- Where did he go?
Where did he go?
He just drove away.
Wait, he just disappeared.
I don't like that he just disappeared.
That's a little- I'm a little worried here.
Wait, wait, I hear him.
He's like close by.
Hello?
Friend?
Where is he?
I literally saw him roll by.
But he left.
All right, that's when you know he's easy.
He ran away.
Okay, let's just get rid of this guy first.
Oh, okay.
Now I realize the recoil for this.
Okay, that- this recoil fucking sucks.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me- let me start tapping.
Let me start- start- oh, okay.
At least this NPC has worse aim than me.
Okay, get closer so I can do this.
There we go.
All right.
No, I was using the worst gun in the game and then when he got closer I swapped my gun to the best gun in the game.
Where did- where did he go?
There was a person here.
He just rolled away just like that?
I don't understand.
I was not a threat.
I literally- wait, what?
Wait, where?
Where?
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me- wait.
An association member?
Wait a minute, where?
Oh, hello?
Oh, it's a rookie.
He's a baby.
He's a baby just like me.
He's a baby just like me, but I don't want to get away- Wait, where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
He disappeared.
Wait, he disappeared again?
Where did he go?
Where- why did they all keep running away?
I don't understand.
I'm so friendly.
How much more friendly could I be?
I just wanted to say hi.
He disappeared.
He was literally right here.
Oh my god, he was literally right here.
I saw him.
Wait, is that him?
Is that- oh no, no, that's just- that's the enemy.
Okay, I need to get rid of these guys.
That's fine.
The ring can't hurt me too much, right?
Right?
There's no way he's gonna shoot me.
Oh shit!
Okay, he is a lot tankier than I expected.
What hit me?
Oh no.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it wasn't- it wasn't people.
It was NPCs.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I've never struggled so much against NPCs.
I don't understand.
Why are they so strong?
When did they become so strong?
What?
It equals minus 800 HP.
Oh my god.
Who made you?
I'm still celebrating!
Why is it still raining?
Okay,
it's okay.
We'll stay here.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
How is it still raining?
If only she could tell the weather.
Everything is killing me.
The nature is killing me.
Guys,
outside is dangerous.
Please, I just wanna make friends.
It's so rough out here.
It's actually so rough.
Right now.
All right, everything will be fine.
Everything is gonna be fine, guys.
We might be like running a little low on HP, but like everything will be fine.
Oh, I don't want to cross the river.
The last time I crossed the river, it was not okay for me.
I'm just gonna go.
I'm just gonna go here.
I am not crossing the river after last time.
It's okay.
I'm gonna make some friends, guys.
I believe.
I believe that we can find some friends.
And nothing bad is gonna happen to us.
Hello?
Everything hurts.
I didn't know...
I didn't know the outside can be this dangerous.
I didn't know.
When did the outside get this bad?
And there's matching?
What could it be?
Okay, let's...
Let's grab...
Wait, there's a fellow association member?
Oh no.
Friend?
Wait, where?
Oh, here.
Friend.
Oh my god, friend.
Flush with the good stuff?
Hmm...
Hello?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's an elevator.
I need the elevator.
Hello, elevator.
NOOOOO!
I wanted to use the elevator!
We could've been friends!
Oh!
Whatever.
We could've been friends!
I don't understand!
What is...
Why is everyone avoiding me?
More friends?
I just...
I'm not even threatening!
I'm just rolling around!
There's no way he doesn't know.
Look at me.
I'm literally a baby.
How would he know?
Hello?
Faint gunfire?
Oh.
Okay.
Hello?
Hi!
Hi, friend!
Wait, is he dead?
Is friend dead?
Wait.
He's busy fighting a bandit.
Oh, you know what that means.
Wait, the bandit's still there.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, that's still a bandit.
Wait, where did the other guy go?
Okay.
It's time to third party.
Oh no, he's on me.
Oh no.
I was trying to look for friend.
They're both bandits!
Where's the other guy?
Wait.
Magus hunter.
Battle recommendations.
Where's the other guy?
Did they all just appear?
Wait, the battle's over?
No, he left.
He ran away.
Oh my god.
I don't understand why all of them are so scared.
There has to be like one guy that would want to be my friend.
No, no.
There was a real guy.
His name was Lost.
We were going to be friends.
We were going to have an adventure together.
But he disappeared.
Why did they run away?
I don't understand.
Is this about teamwork?
And friendship?
Is it?
This is basically reverse stream sniping.
I'll get rid of these guys.
These guys are scary.
These guys like explode on you.
And I don't want to deal with that.
I found like three people.
And they all ran away.
It's actually crazy.
I did not expect like everybody to just disappear.
Oh, it's back here.
It's this door again.
Someone has to use the escape pod, right?
Okay, I'm going to travel a little bit more.
I don't understand.
Like, look at me.
What is there to be afraid of?
Like, oh my god.
Okay, we need to find shelter.
Just in case it starts raining.
I don't have the weather feature.
Where's... I heard...
I heard people running around.
Is that friend?
Friend!
Oh my god, friend!
Hello, friend!
Friend!
Do you not want to be friends with me?
Oh my god.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, that's a bandit.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
That was just a bandit.
That was an NPC.
That's another NPC.
Is there, like, anybody that's real?
Are there real people?
In my game?
Okay.
Wait, there's a friend right here.
Friend.
I'm going to slowly walk up to him.
And then, non-threateningly.
And then he'll be like, Oh my god, are you a good person?
And I'll be like, yeah!
She said with confidence.
Oh, come on.
Look at me.
Look at me!
Come on!
Oh, there she is.
Hello!
Oh, origin!
Wait.
Drifter's soul.
Wait, isn't that...
Hello!
I'm a new...
I'm a new player!
Hi!
Wait, he's ignoring me.
Oh, he said hello!
Okay, do you think he'll let me get close?
Run away, Drifter.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm pretty sure he'll want to be friends, right?
Okay, I need to figure out how to get up though.
Give me a sec.
I need to figure out how to parkour.
Where did he go?
Wait, why is he running away?
Oh, that's a bandit.
Wait, is that...
Hello!
Hi!
Friend?
Hello?
Hi!
Yeah?
I'm so happy to see you!
I feel like I don't...
I never see other people.
Can we play together?
Hi!
There?
We can work together to kill bandits together.
Yeah!
Don't worry, I'll help you.
I can help you.
Oh my god, wait.
He actually knows how to play this game.
Wait a minute.
Look at him dodge and weave.
I think he actually knows how to play, guys.
I'm a little...
I'm a little worried.
Yeah, he actually...
He's like using...
He's using cover and everything.
He's actually playing...
Okay, I'm gonna pretend to help him.
And I'm gonna be like...
But then he's gonna see me be like really bad.
So he's gonna be like...
Oh, that's cute that he's like trying, you know?
That's cute that he's trying his best, you know?
But then I'm like...
But where did he go?
Wait, where did he go though?
How am I supposed to third party him if he just runs away?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait a minute.
No, he disappeared my target!
He disappeared!
How am I supposed to steal his legs?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Where did he go?
He disappeared!
He was here!
Okay, we have to leave anyway.
We have five minutes left.
Five minutes before the fun begins.
I just realized what time it is.
He like disappeared!
I had a whole plan and everything!
No legs today.
When will I ever get my legs?
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
I was gonna third party!
I was gonna give him like a full sense of security!
And then I was gonna shoot him in the back!
And then now he's gone!
Now he's just gone.
I can't believe it.
This has been the hardest PvP run I've ever had.
Yes, last time!
Last time I like...
Oh my god, last time was so easy.
Like people were so...
Like people...
Nobody ran away.
And everybody wanted to be friends.
But like...
I don't understand.
Like...
You can tell I look like a baby.
I don't understand!
Like...
Another Kratos?
Someone else wants to use it too.
Okay.
Someone else here.
There's someone else here.
I said another Kratos.
Where are they?
How did people learn?
I thought like everybody would be nice.
Like no...
Nobody would be hardened by the lies.
And cruel fate of the world.
Nobody else here wants to escape.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
No one else wants to be my friend.
The world is so messed up.
The world...
No one wants to be...
I swear everybody just ran away from me.
I don't understand.
My entire mission was to just...
Make friends.
I think it is my first stream sniper.
You're all so mean.
I don't understand.
Alright.
How many people have I missed out on?
Oh, there's me walking around.
Look.
Okay.
I saw this guy.
I saw him.
Where did he go?
We literally saw this man.
Where the hell did he go?
Time to see all the PvP we missed.
Like, he just ran away.
He was right here.
This entire time.
He was right here this entire time.
He just stood there and watched me.
Okay.
Oh, and then he just...
He just left.
He was right here this entire time.
He was...
He was just watching me.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait.
How did I miss like 20?
Oh my god.
What the...
Oh no.
That's the bandit.
I was gonna be like, excuse me.
What the heck is that?
Okay.
Alright.
So we saw this.
I need to know how many other people I missed out on.
Okay.
There's rain.
And then...
Why are the bandits like half-naked men?
Okay.
There's Lawrence right there.
I saw Lawrence.
Yeah.
I wanted to meet up with Lawrence.
And then...
I just walked past Lawrence?
Where was Lawrence?
Okay.
And then I saw this guy.
This guy was the one I...
This guy I was trying to find.
Oh, and then...
He legitimately just walked past all the other hunters.
And then there's one more guy over here too.
And...
There were three other people right here and I didn't see any of...
I'm so blind.
There were three other people around me and I didn't see them.
But like, where did he go?
Like, I...
Where did he go?
Okay.
And then...
I lost him here.
I lost him right here.
I was watching him fight these three bandits.
And then he just disappeared.
Where did he go?
He just left!
He just...
Oh my...
They all...
Lawrence is still there!
Just sitting...
Let's just say that Lawrence is still just sitting there.
Like...
I traveled halfway across...
And Lawrence never moved him.
He's just surviving.
He was just still there.
I... Oh my god.
Legend said he's actually...
He's still just...
Still there.
Just sitting there.
Some say he's still there to this day.
Please.
My only mission is to make a friend.
That's all I want.
Why do they all want to run away from me?
I don't understand.
Do they not want to be my friend?
I look so welcoming.
I went on three expeditions...
And everybody keeps running away from me.
I...
I can't even do any missions...
Because I'm too busy trying to make friends.
Oh, I know.
I have a strat.
I'm going to carry...
Extra materials.
And then when I see a friend...
I'm going to drop some of my loot.
And then...
And then they'll turn their backs on me.
Oh my god.
I'm so smart.
Okay, this is my new strat, guys.
Alright, let me see.
I need to grab...
New health packs real quick.
And then I'm going to grab this healing kit.
Because I'm getting...
I'm accidentally like...
And then I'm going to grab...
I'm going to give them...
I'm going to grab ammo.
I'm going to grab extra ammo.
And then throw...
Oh, you're right.
I'm going to rain shields.
You're right.
You're so right.
I'm going to grab extra medkits.
And I'm going to drop medkits to them.
I'm going to grab one of each.
And I'm just going to drop medkits.
What are you trying to trick?
They'll just think I'm really friendly.
Guys, they're just going to think...
I'm really, really friendly.
This is it.
This is where I'm going to finally make friends.
This is it, guys.
I'm going to finally make a friend.
It's like RuneScape, you know?
It's like ye olde RuneScape scams.
Surely it'll work in this game.
It has worked for decades.
In RuneScape.
It shall work in Simuality.
Echo of Ada.
Free gold trimming here, guys.
Free armor trimming.
All you have to do is just drop your armor.
And then I'll trim it for you.
I have played these games before.
Alright, this time.
Surely I'll make a new friend here.
Surely it'll be different.
Alright, let's see.
Did I take out my legs?
No, it's the same legs.
Oh wait, hey, there's loot here.
Okay, my entire mission...
I'm not here to upgrade my house or anything.
It's just to make one friend.
That's all I want to do.
Hello.
I want to make a friend in my extraction shooter game.
Hello, everybody.
Anybody here?
Surely there's one mecha that wants to talk to me.
What about that we are not doing a bathtub?
I refuse to give my wife a bathtub.
If I can't shower, she can't shower.
Okay, I hate...
Okay, nice.
These take two shots!
These guys take two shots but then the other one takes like 20.
Okay, friend.
Hello!
Anybody wants to be my friend?
There's a faint sound of an engine.
There's a friend nearby.
Antenna?
There has to be.
There's someone rolling around.
Okay.
These are bandits, so they're like NPCs.
But like, where's...
Where's real people?
Hello?
Any friendships here?
Hello, I'm just a little baby learning how to play the game.
And like, nothing bad's gonna happen to you when we get close together.
We're just gonna have a good time.
We're gonna work together.
Gathering materials and resources.
Like good friends should do.
Hello?
Hello, anybody?
Why is it so quiet?
Hello?
Please!
It's so lonely!
I'm so alone!
Please!
I'm like the last mech on Earth!
Please, it's so lonely!
I'm gonna bet Toki ran past 20 people.
I'm so alone!
Is there anybody that wanna be my friend?
Please!
I keep killing my friends.
I can't even say that!
I haven't killed a single soul!
I rode all the way here and not a single soul has been found!
Alright.
It's alright.
Any dragoons too?
Oh wait, no.
Oh wait, these are like regular.
Oh my god, that's right.
Okay, that was a little scary.
That was not gonna lie, a little scary.
I thought I was gonna get hit.
There has to be like at least one person around.
Alright, we're gonna go here.
Let's see if we can see anything.
I keep using emotes instead of...
Instead of doing like the crystal search.
Oh my god!
Almost shot my wife.
Not the green ones!
The green ones are strong!
I don't trust the green ones.
Hello?
Anybody?
Anybody here?
Please?
I just wanna be somebody's friend!
I'm here to bring free armor trimming here!
I'm here to drop free armor trimming!
How do I drop?
Look at that!
Free armor trimming right here!
Faint sound of engine.
There's one nearby.
Where are they?
Faint...
Faint engine.
That means there's someone nearby.
Where could they be?
Come on.
I hear them.
My wife said she heard somebody.
Hello?
You guys heard that?
Guys, I swear I'm not going crazy.
I heard something.
I swear.
There's no way I'm not going crazy, guys.
Something came up.
Hello?
Anybody?
Please?
I'm gonna go insane.
I don't even want to kill no more.
I just want to know that I'm not alone.
Hello?
Wait!
Friend!
Hello?
Coffin Ogre!
Hi!
Oh my god!
Hey there!
Can I follow you?
Hi!
Hi there!
I was so alone!
I was looking for somebody for the longest time!
I thought I was alone.
I thought I was the last mech on Earth.
I was desperate for human contact.
Sir, please stop right away!
Why?
Why are you running away from me?
Please!
Come back!
He knows!
Where did he go?
He actually disappeared!
Please!
Drifter, please!
I was so alone!
Why are you running?
I just wanted human contact!
I was so alone and I was scared!
Don't shoot me!
I just want friends!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
You're real!
You're a real person!
Let's stay together!
You're real!
Let's all work together!
I'll give you something.
Do you want that?
Look at that!
Oh my god!
Let's walk together!
Let's build a friendship together!
Drifter!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
What do you want to do?
Yeah?
Oh!
Wait!
Don't!
Don't leave me!
Can I follow you?
Hey!
I thought we were friends!
Stop!
Don't run away!
Can I follow you?
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
Come on!
Let's all walk together!
Nothing bad is gonna happen to us!
Whoa!
Wait, what happened?
What is that?
What are you doing?
What?
I don't think I can...
What did he do?
What?
Are these...
Are these things that you can...
Oh, it's his later mission.
Wait, how...
Wait, how high level is this guy?
I'm just a baby.
There's nothing wrong.
It's rain!
We should get cover!
To get there?
Oh!
Oh, thank you!
Wait, why did he give me my repair kit back?
Wait, that's another drifter!
Who is he?
Oh my god, let's all...
Let's all sit down here...
And become good friends!
Who's this?
Hey there!
Hey friend!
We're all good friends now, right?
Hello?
Oh my god, there's three of us now!
Oh, he is?
Hey!
Hi!
My new target...
Because he's a baby just like me.
Hahaha!
Friend 2!
Hey!
Come on, I dropped this for you!
Rearmor trimming!
The other target, I was like...
Hey!
Rearmor trimming!
Wait, he's not taking it!
Oh, he took the bait!
He took it!
He took the bait!
He knew it!
Okay, it's working!
It's working!
Okay, wait, I got an idea!
Take this!
There's a rope here!
Yeah, you don't want the rope?
Oh, I know what you want!
Hahaha!
Oh!
Hey!
Hahaha!
Hahahaha!
He was...
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
I told you.
Oh shit, where did I put my heels?
He walked away.
Guys, it's okay.
He walked away, guys.
Oh no!
No!
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I swear.
I swear he did it first.
He shot first.
I swear to god.
I swear to god he shot first.
I swear.
Please.
I did it.
I found him like that.
I swear to god I found him like that.
I swear.
I swear to god.
He was like that when I got there, didn't he?
Wait, I didn't steal his legs.
Let me get his legs first.
Let me get my trophy.
Let me get my trophy real fast.
Guys, this is... Oh no.
Oh no.
Wait, there's... I hear them.
I can't get my trophy if they come down.
I swear.
He turned around and he was just dead.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to get my trophy?
He hit me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Can you get rid of stuff?
What's my inventory limit?
Okay.
Why can't I grab the legs?
No, it's 300.
Oh.
Hello.
Hi.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't... He shot first.
He shot first, I swear to god.
He shot first.
Look, look.
He... I swear.
He shot first.
I swear to god.
I swear he shot first.
I tore the body.
It wasn't me.
Oh.
I swear to god.
He shot first.
Let me grab the legs.
Please.
I didn't mean it.
I gotta leave the scene of the crime.
Oh no.
There's no way.
Who shot me?
It wasn't the other guy.
It was someone new.
It wasn't even the original guy.
It was a different guy that shot me.
He was spectating.
He was a witness, but where was he?
There was a witness that I didn't know of.
There was a witness that I didn't know existed.
I don't even know who the witness was.
There was a peeping tom that saw everything.
Oh my god.
I know I'm trying to get to a safe place.
I don't trust the other area.
There was a witness everyone, but I don't know where he went.
Where did he come from?
The other guy looked away.
The thing is, the first guy, he looked away.
He judged me, but he looked away and pretended nothing happened.
There was a secret second witness that I do not know of.
I don't know where he... No, not the rain.
Not the rain.
I don't know where to go.
I need to head to the... I need to find a way to... Oh no, I have to go here.
This has to be closer.
I need to figure out how to get there though.
I'm so lost.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
I only have two minutes.
I'm so lost, everyone.
Okay, okay, this is it.
I'm trying!
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no.
Two minutes.
I'm cutting it so close right now.
I'm overheated.
I'm trying my best.
Wait, wait.
I think it's the second witness.
I think he's hunting me down.
Oh my god, the second witness is hunting me down.
Oh my god, I hear the second witness.
He's near me.
He's nearby.
The second witness is nearby.
I hear him.
I actually hear him.
He's somewhere near me.
The second witness...
Hello?
Oh my god.
He saw me!
Oh, wait, wait, no.
He's friendly.
Wait, is he not the second witness?
Was he not the hidden cop?
Is he?
Oh fuck, I don't know.
I don't know if he was the secret cop.
I don't know.
10, 14, 13, 12, 11, 10, 9, 7...
No!
He was!
He was the second witness!
No!
He was!
He was the cop this entire time!
It was him!
I couldn't tell!
I couldn't tell if he
was...
I thought I counted correctly.
He saw everything.
He actually saw everything.
Oh my god.
Crap doesn't pay.
I can't believe it.
I knew he was the cop!
I could tell he was the cop by trying to like... See, I could sneak into the elevator.
I can't believe it.
No, he was the witness.
He saw me kill the first baby.
He saw me.
He was the one that was up in the hill with a fucking sniper and saw it all.
My DLC legs.
Wait, what?
He took my wife?
Wait,
did he take my wife?
Oh my god, are you okay?
Oh, oh man.
Okay.
Um.
Oh.
I don't.
Hello.
Um.
Oh.
You'll lose all the items you're carrying.
You'll lose.
You can pick up starter items for free though.
Oh.
You're running low on ceiling kits.
Better stock up before the next sorting.
Maybe I should have let him take my wife.
Maybe I'm the shithead.
Oh man.
My legs.
My beautiful legs.
They're all gone.
There must be.
Wait, I must be able to buy starter guns, right?
250?
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
I can buy the starter shotgun.
Okay.
And then, there we go.
Things will be fine.
I can't believe they took my legs.
I can't believe it.
I'm angry now.
I'm so angry.
Wait, I got new legs!
Oh, but it's not the same.
My DLC legs that I got for free because I got sponsored.
Now they got my DLC legs.
They got it.
What's the point?
Wait.
Not the exclusive legs.
I had to preorder.
Oh my god.
Now it's like they don't even have to spend...
I lost my sponsor merch, guys.
He took my merch.
He took my Jordans.
Alright, fix up my home.
I'm sad now.
I can't believe it.
I didn't realize he saw.
The other drifter looked away.
I didn't have enough bribes.
What?
Alright, nice.
So you just make... She basically does nothing.
It says she upgraded the floor, but it looks just as messed up as before.
I don't know.
That's definitely... Look, she's still learning.
My wife is still learning, guys.
She was born last week, so guys, come on.
Guys, please.
Have mercy on my wife.
We got beat up.
We got robbed, okay?
We got robbed by an undercover cop.
Like how?
Come on, guys.
We're having it really rough right now.
We don't even have a bathroom.
She has to look like this right now.
You did this to her.
I was brought to justice.
I was unarmed.
He shot an unarmed citizen who was with his wife.
I was with my wife.
That's the ceiling?
How did I...
Oh my god.
No, please don't.
No, we're so poor and now we're eating weeds too.
Oh no, she's feeding me weed.
I forgot.
Oh my god.
We're not... Our home life is not okay right now.
Our home life is really rough right now.
We can't even afford real food.
We can't even afford real... I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'm so sad.
I'll be right back.
Look, just because my wife can't use the bathroom doesn't mean I can't either.
Okay, guys.
At least one of us has to win something.
Okay, we're gonna do this strat again because it clearly worked out for us.
So all we need to do is we're gonna put some... We're gonna grab some health packs.
And then so like they'll think I'll be like free armor trimmings again.
And it's gonna... It worked.
It worked.
What I... I just didn't bring enough armor trimming for the other witnesses.
Okay, I just... I didn't bring enough, guys.
I brought enough for one witness and he looked away.
But I didn't bring enough for two witnesses.
I didn't bribe enough people.
That's the thing.
It did work.
I just didn't account for a second bribe.
I... I didn't bribe the cops, okay?
I forgot about bribing the cops to get away with murder.
That was my problem.
That was... And it's raining?
Like I came in here and it has to rain?
Where the... Where is the crowd?
Are you serious?
I just got here.
How could it rain now?
Okay.
Alright, let's figure out how to get out of... Let's figure out how to get covered.
I can't believe it's raining.
I literally just got here.
I just arrived.
Alright.
These guys die super fast.
Nice.
Okay, and then let's grab some...
Oh my god.
Not having good nigs sucks so much.
Like, what do I do when I can't zoom zoom?
Oh.
Stop dissing the weatherman.
I can't believe it.
I didn't bring enough bribes.
I... I forgot to pay off the police.
I paid off the... I paid off the residents, but not the police.
No sign of pursuit.
Who was I escaping from?
Okay, we gotta... we gotta go here.
We must bump into somebody.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I figured out how to win.
It's alright.
I have like... I have... I have like stronger armor too.
Oh my god, it's taking so long.
What do we do to this world?
Why is it still raining?
I don't understand.
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay.
We just need to wait until the rain stops.
I'm gonna have the shittier gun out so they won't see me as a threat.
So they know what they think.
Like, oh, she doesn't know what she's doing.
She has the... she has the bad gun.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
Don't harvest me.
I'm just a... I... I just have money.
That's it.
Please don't harvest me.
I paid for this DLC.
Please.
I actually got it for free, but they don't know that.
They'll be like, oh my god, this poor guy.
This poor guy.
She really wanted to play this game and paid for the DLC for the DLC armor parts.
Like, we're not gonna hurt her.
Alright, here we go.
Oh hey, nice.
Wait, we needed these crystals anyway.
Let's excavate this real fast.
Be careful, Doki.
There are dragoons out.
There's no way.
A dragoon would want to let me have... a dragoon would want me to have their legs.
Are you serious?
Oh no, not the green end.
These guys are so annoying.
They're so strong!
Okay, I'm gonna slap you.
Oh my god, I'm...
Oh, now you're gonna run, you little bitch?
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Alright, let's go over here.
The other dragoons would want me to collect their legs as a trophy.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
There's a faint sound of an engine.
That means there's people rolling by near me.
Hello, friends?
Friends!
Hello, any vulnerable mechs out there that would like to be friends with me?
I am just a lowly poor mecha...
that wants to befriend all the other mechas in the town.
Let me just slap them real fast.
Reload.
Hello?
Hello, any kind-hearted mechs...
that wanna travel the mecha world with me...
but nothing bad happens?
Hello?
Anybody?
Come on!
Don't we all love friendship here?
Wait, faint gunfire?
Okay, that means it's like...
Okay, it's definitely close by.
But there's faint gunfire.
Hello?
Hello, friends?
I'm just a baby.
I don't know what I'm doing.
He's right here.
Oh, he's right here.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, excuse me?
Wait, an excavation person died.
Wait a minute.
That's a little concerning.
There is a dead excavation member here.
Okay, um...
I'm a little worried now.
Somebody killed someone near me.
And it wasn't me.
Wait, what?
Where?
There's an...member?
Down here?
He said there's like 20 different things.
Are they here?
Caution?
Wait a minute.
We gotta leave.
That's a killer.
I was like, why he gold?
And then I'm like...
Oh...
Oh, he...
He's gold.
I was like...
Wait, that's a...
That's a weird color.
I've never seen that color before.
I...
Oh, that is definitely not friend-shaped, guys.
That is...
That is not friend-shaped.
Guys, you thought I was like...
This guy actually kills for fun.
He wasn't...
You see, I'm being paid to kill for fun.
This guy...
He paid...
He paid Bandai to kill for fun.
Like...
I got paid by Bandai to kill for fun.
But he paid Bandai for this.
So you know...
You know I'm dead.
I'm...
That's when I know I have to run.
That's...
Sounds fun.
That's when I know.
He doesn't put the love of the game in nothing else.
Yeah, I gotta leave.
I don't trust that man.
I 100% do not trust him.
Alright, let's just move on.
I don't...
I don't trust...
I don't think I...
What is this?
Alright, let's see what we can find.
Any crystals.
Oh, we have the escape pod here.
Hello?
Hello, tiger.
Hi.
Hey.
Hey, you want some loot?
Here.
Here, buddy.
Hey.
You want this?
Hello?
Thanks.
Can I come over and...
Look, look, look.
I don't mean to hurt you.
I don't mean to harm you.
Come on.
I don't mean to hurt you.
Here.
Wait, where did it go?
Wait, where did I drop it?
Wait, where did I drop my thing?
Where did it go?
Did it fall into this?
Where did my...
Where did my heals go?
Hello?
Hey, hey, hey, come here.
Here, here, here.
Here.
Take this.
I forgot to shoot.
I got it wrong.
I was gonna shoot him.
God damn it, I forgot to shoot.
I was trying to pick up my items.
I wanted to pick it up.
I was trying to pick up my heals and I forgot to shoot him.
Because I was like, wait a minute, I don't want to lose this.
I didn't want to lose my heals.
And he fell.
I lost my heals too because I glitched into the goddamn elevator.
I don't win.
I just don't win.
I was like, wait a minute, I don't want to lose this.
I donated my items to the elevator.
And she actually made them for us.
I was like, oh no, I don't want to lose this.
I don't want to lose this item.
She is so fucking devilish.
I'm so sad.
I was so...
The elevator has been fed.
It was so nice to trip that guy's armor for free.
I'm so sad.
I was so close.
Oh my god.
I was just like, oh man.
My item.
I'm so sad.
I'm so scared about my item.
Hey guys, hey.
Oh my god, look at his legs.
Oh, that could have been...
Okay, I'm doing one more.
That could have been my legs.
Because he didn't even have a shotgun.
I'm so sad.
I got so preoccupied with making sure I picked up my items.
I forgot to shoot.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I'm seeing you log some progress for a request.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
One more.
I need at least one murder.
I need...
I need a...
I need one trophy leg.
That's all I want.
I need...
I need one trophy leg.
I don't need much.
I just need to be able to have one leg.
That's all I want.
I need one trophy leg.
I donated all my goddamn heals.
Okay.
Armor trimming.
I got my armor trimming right here.
Okay, manage, divide.
Okay, wait.
How do I...
How do I divide this?
Okay.
One.
Okay, there we go.
And then...
There we go.
I have two armor trimmings right there.
Okay, this is it.
This is where...
This is where we're gonna do it.
This is it.
Alright.
We're gonna...
I need one...
I just need one trophy leg.
That's it.
I don't care.
I need to bring back home a trophy leg.
I need...
I need to bring home just...
That's all I asked for.
That's...
That's all I need.
A trophy.
Also, I just got word from the devs...
And the code does not expire.
So...
So, do not...
You don't have to rush to get it.
The code doesn't expire.
I just got word.
So, good news, everybody.
Good news.
Alright.
Okay, this time it'll work, guys.
I can scam somebody.
This time.
I think I'll be like...
Wow, Doki, you did it.
You actually made a friend.
Doki, isn't that what you wanted all along?
I thought you wanted to make a friend all along, Doki.
Isn't that what you were trying to accomplish?
Yeah.
A friend.
Okay.
Alright.
Surely, we'll meet somebody.
Friend?
Any friends here?
Wait, what?
What's left behind?
Oh, wait.
That's somebody's body.
At least...
Oh, wait.
No.
They're like the bandits, right?
Friends?
You should be...
I'm so happy, guys.
I've always wanted to make...
I've always wanted a brother.
Oh, somebody's been killing all these bandits.
There's a bandit killer here.
Which is good because I don't have to worry about the bandits shooting me.
Hello, everyone!
I'm here for friends.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Anyone at all?
That's why I know.
That's why I need to avoid that.
Wait, that geezer is shooting someone.
He's shooting somebody.
That means someone's here.
Hello?
Hi.
What the fuck?
What?
Why did he put the shield up?
I'm not trustworthy!
Why did you put the shield up?
He built a wall!
He built a goddamn wall!
He didn't even trust me!
He didn't even say hi!
He actually built a wall.
All I did was like, hi.
I didn't even get a chance to say hi and he built a wall.
That man had zero trust.
He said not today.
Trust nobody.
I didn't even say hi.
He just assumed I was gonna kill him.
I mean, I was going to.
He didn't have to assume it right away.
What happened to trust, guys?
What happened to friendship here?
What happened to innocent before proven guilty?
Kids these days.
Guy has kids.
Wait, there's a...
Wait, there is a...
There's another friend nearby.
They auto-blocked for animal request.
There's an engine nearby.
Wait, what's that?
Wait, there's...
There's someone here.
They opened it.
Hello!
What?
I don't understand.
Why does everyone leave?
I just...
No reason.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
What happened to innocent until proven guilty?
When did children not stop trusting others?
That's so messed up, guys.
They know what you wanted to do.
Word has spread of your armor trimmings.
Word has spread.
Wait, he's shooting somebody.
Wait, that thing.
That NPC.
He's chasing after someone.
You were proven.
They don't know that.
How do they know?
This is my fresh run.
How would they know?
Okay, that guy is chasing after someone.
Wait, I thought he was chasing after somebody.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
Wait, they clearly...
That was chasing someone.
It was chasing somebody.
I thought I saw him chasing someone.
Let me just kill this real fast.
There we go.
Oh my god, there has to be more people here.
Alright, I'm gonna make some noise.
Gonna make some noise.
Come on, I just need one leg.
Just one leg.
Like...
One tiny leg.
That's all I asked for.
That's all... I'm just committing one crime.
I commit one crime.
Like, everybody gets one pass, you know?
Like, you know how like when you're a child, you can commit like...
You know, you can do one wrong thing.
This is my one wrong thing.
That's all I want.
Can I not just commit one thing and then I'll be like an upstanding citizen for the rest of my life?
And then after that, I won't do anything bad ever again.
No, you don't know that.
I bribe...
I bribe witnesses.
It's not even on my record.
Oh my god.
Okay, I might need to heal though.
I might need to heal after that.
I need to make sure I'm full HP for my crime.
Wait, wait, wait.
There has to be like...
At least one.
Let me get rid of this guy real fast.
Come on, one guy!
One guy!
I can't get one guy!
Give me a sec.
I need to find shelter now.
I need to find cover.
The ring!
There's too many polygons on the ring too!
Okay, crawler.
There has to be cover somewhere here.
We're literally in the city.
There has to be one cover.
I didn't bring any...
I didn't bring any mega armor heals here.
There has to be... Oh my god, please.
I just need like a tiny bit of cover, please.
Oh...
Oh, of course the weather gets better when I... Oh my god, the weather gets better when I...
When I'm trying to find the cover.
Loli, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You want their leg?
I don't know you...
Okay, I'm not finishing that super chat.
I'm not finishing that super chat.
Like, where did everybody go?
Where did they all go?
I don't want to stray too far from the escape portal.
Because like the other ones are like...
One is like all the way here and the other one is like all the way on the other side.
So like I want to be close to...
I want to be sure I'm like here.
Like close to here so I don't have to worry.
Everything is just PvE.
Hello?
Any friends?
I just played this game today and all I want to do is make a friend so I can tell everybody...
How a wonderful experience I had and how everybody was so nice and kind to me.
Like and we all want to work together.
Like I just want to spread the good word about how...
Everyone here...
Wants to work together and like...
Become good friends with me and like...
We all go on many adventures together and it's crazy how...
A lifelong 10 year friendship started because of...
Senuality, Echo of Ada.
That's all I want.
The lies.
No, no, no, no.
I'm just really lonely.
Cut stuff.
I sound so pathetic.
I sound so pathetic right now.
I don't want to be the last mech alive.
Wait, I hear...
Wait, there's bandits here.
But he's shooting somebody.
He was shooting someone.
Okay, that's a bandit but...
Where's the...
Where's the regular...
Wait.
The battle is over.
But where is the...
Where's the cradle?
Where are they?
I don't understand.
Where is...
I just want one person.
One person...
Wait.
Wait, is he chasing after somebody?
No, he's just rolling around.
Hello?
Is there anybody that wants to go see the bandit?
There's a lot of really juicy loot over here.
Hello?
Look at all that juicy loot.
Just lying around.
Oh my god.
I'm never gonna...
I either find nobody or I find five people.
That wants me dead.
There's no in between.
Or somehow I made a friend.
After everything I've been through, I just made...
I would make a friend.
It's not gonna work?
Then how do I find people?
How?
How can one achieve friendship?
Did you hear that?
Did you hear that, guys?
Wait, I heard something.
Okay, no, that's a bandit.
No, I heard something.
I swear.
I heard something.
I swear to god.
It wasn't a bandit.
It was like a real person.
I swear to god, I'm not crazy.
I heard a real person just then.
I swear.
Oh my god.
I'm not going crazy.
I'm not.
I swear, I'm not.
There was a real person.
I heard the... I heard the engine.
I heard it the moment we look at the map.
The moment we look at the map, we'll know.
This has to be the hardest mission I've ever had.
Finding one real... finding a friend.
I'm not hearing things.
I'm not going crazy.
There was a real person.
Okay, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go to the...
Okay, that...
Whoops.
Guys, there's fall damage if you forgot.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, there's no way that hits me.
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no way.
I'd be so sad if that actually hit me.
This is quite the rare item.
Okay, maybe I'm...
We don't have a reason to attack them.
Hello.
And how are you today?
I've detected the drive sounds of an incoming cradle.
Oh, hello.
Do you want me to...
This one's in good standing with the Association.
No!
Incoming fire.
The source is...
Oh my god.
The Association member?
That's right.
That's fucking right!
I'm better!
I'm so much better than you!
That's right!
Oh my god, you got him!
Bro, I was gonna do armor trimming!
Oh my god, if I died to...
If I died to an NPC after everything I've been through, I would have been so sad.
I got a leg!
I got a leg, everybody!
Oh my god, why does he take 20 years to kill?
How is he still alive?
Oh my god, I can't loop because he's like on me.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, I got the leg.
I got the leg, everyone.
I'm stealing your husband!
I'm gonna steal your goddamn husband!
Oh my god!
Where's your legs?!
That's right!
I stole your husband!
Beta male, here's your goddamn beta male!
I need cover.
I swear to god, if I die before...
Oh my god, if I swear to god, after everything I've been through and I die because of rain, I'm so sad.
I'd be so sad.
Disapply.
They self-destructed so I don't have legs?!
Hello.
Hi.
Woah, woah, woah.
What the hell?
Battery remaining?
Half.
How are you today?
One of your rounds almost hit an assassination target.
Play with fire and we'll debrief you once we're back in the garage.
We still made it.
I got a little caught.
I was like, I want two pairs of legs.
That's awkward.
That was awkward.
I got, I was like, but what if I had two pairs of legs?
I'm so sad, he self-destructed just to prevent me from stealing his legs.
There were two people right here and I didn't see them.
I was like, I told you, I wasn't hearing things.
I knew I heard them.
I told you I wasn't hearing things.
I knew I heard, there were four, there were seven people around me.
Oh my god.
There were actually seven people around me.
And I didn't see any of them.
I thought I was alone.
I knew I wasn't crazy.
There were four right here.
Oh my god.
I was just walking around trying to find one guy.
They were Bruce and Steve Snipes.
Oh my god.
Hiding from the serial killer.
I killed two people and now I'm a criminal?
I don't know about that.
That feels a bit unfair.
It feels a little bit unfair.
One of them was self-defense, technically.
Technically, one of them was self-defense.
I was gonna do my armor trim scam and he shot me.
I don't understand why.
It wasn't like my scam was gonna hurt anybody.
Like...
My scam wasn't actually gonna hurt no one.
Who did I kill?
He asked for that fight.
He could've had a free health kit.
Wait, but like, who was it?
Who was the guy I killed?
I like how I never left this area.
Wait, that was...
That was a trap!
Who was it?
Murray, I stole your husband.
What you gonna do about it?
Yeah, it was a trap.
That's right.
If you want your husband back, you gotta pay for it.
Oh my god, that was...
No wonder he did not believe me.
That's the other dragoon I tried to tell.
That's right, you gotta pay for him back.
This is a hostage situation.
I demand a ransom.
I'm demanding a ransom right now.
I like how he...
I like how he like, armored up and like, put on health too.
He did not trust me at all.
And I almost got away with it too.
I almost got away with it.
Zero fate.
You guys wanna see the guy I kidnapped?
Wait, where is it?
Where's the guy I kidnapped?
Look at that.
I got $280,000!
That's right, if you want your husband back, I demand $280,000.
I rescued him.
We're rich!
It's okay, this is better than legs.
Guys, this is actually better than legs.
I stole some... I kidnapped somebody and got rewarded for it.
Woah, kidnapping's pretty profitable.
Yay!
Finally, we end on a high.
We end on a goddamn high.
It works!
Kidnapping works, let's go!
End game.
End game, guys.
Yay!
Let's apply what we learned.
What did we learn today, dragons?
What did we learn today?
Alright, I think it was a good time to call it.
Wow, what a wild... I feel like every playthrough gets more wild.
Every playthrough, something new happens, guys.
Anyway, it was a great time streaming for all of you guys.
Especially for the new viewers on Bandai's official channel on YouTube and Twitch.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBrain.
I am an indie VTuber specializing in FPS and shooter-type games.
And that's why I'm here to talk about Senuality.
Senuality for you guys.
And I do have an exclusive cosmetic, as you see my waifu is wearing.
It's a little dirty.
We got sort of messed up earlier.
But if you want to unlock this code, it's not time-limited.
It can be unlocked on any platforms, by the way.
So if you have a game on console or PC, you can unlock this t-shirt.
And it's not limited, so you can unlock it whenever.
So a huge thank you to Bandai for the sponsor.
I will be dropping the code.
The code is pinned in my chat.
And also it's on my screen right now at the bottom left, as you see.
You just type the code down.
Here I am putting in the chat in my own YouTube channel chat.
So if you guys liked what you saw, if you guys are interested in my channel, I do a lot of variety stuff.
As well as other FPS games, other shooter-type games.
You can subscribe to me on YouTube for Doki Bird.
I'm also on Twitch at Doki Bird.
And if you guys didn't know, I try to stream almost every day.
And I do a lot of other stuff too.
Also if you guys want to know how to unlock this shirt, it's very easy.
You just go to...
You have to play through the tutorial, by the way, to do this.
You just go to Other, and then click Serial Code Entry right here.
And then paste the code right here.
And then you can unlock it.
If you want to see the shirt right away, you have to return to the main menu.
Return to the title.
And then just log back in.
And then you should get it.
So like I said, this is an extraction shooter.
So we did die, and then we lost everything.
But it's okay.
I stole somebody's...
I stole somebody's husband and made back all the money.
So kidnapping is okay in this game.
I might not have got any legs today, but like I got...
I got somebody's man.
I am not a homewrecker, okay?
I rescued him.
It was a rescue mission.
I am not a homewrecker.
Hey guys, huge shoutout to Bandai.
Thank you again.
Thank you again for sponsoring me.
I had a great time going through the whole entire journey.
Uplink, Senuality, Echo Beta.
I think I've done like three playthroughs with them.
And it's been quite a journey.
So yes, thank you again.
And I'm really happy that I got to be part of an actual official Bandai game.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you sail for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.